alors que de belles et bonnes choses
l'homme peut créer un lien avec la
nature
quand on voit nos prairies maigres
fleuri les pâturages les arbres
fruitiers les murs en pierres sèches les
vignes tout ce que l'homme a pu créer
c'est un grand patrimoine qu'on a et jeu
mettra en opposition caton quand on
choisit comme seul paramètre la
rentabilité la surproductivité la
croissance en commun comme roy l'argent
comme rennes la machine on oublie
vraiment l'homme et la nature
et moi je suis mon thème ce serait de le
remettre au milieu avec la nature donc
ne pas oublier que la nature elle fait
partie avec nous sur cette terre et je
voudrais pas se réunit des deux pôles
isoler complètement de faire des
réserves naturelles des parcs nationaux
c'est bien aussi c'est utile mais aussi
nous garder aussi pour notre quotidien
aussi de la nature ne pas couper l'homme
au milieu
l'homme il a tellement de la nature
qu'il faut toujours qu'ils aillent plus
loin plus le plus haut toujours plus
haut dans la montagne plus loin dans des
paysages exotiques où il ya encore de la
nature sauvage
ils recherchent ça ils font des biens
ferrata dans les coins sauvages parce
qu'il a tellement besoin mais pour finir
on pourra pas les tellement plus loin ce
ne pourra pas recréer des routes pour
aller plus haut en montagne donc je me
dis ça nous rattrape
on va dans les villes les plus éloignés
et on trouve les mêmes chaînes de cafés
les mêmes chaînes de magasins et je
trouve ça dommage pour la diversité pour
qu'est ce que l'homme a besoin pour être
dans la joie et quand on quand on garde
j'avais deux exemples par rapport au
savoir faire à la topographie un autre
climat tout ce qu'on a comme diversité
tout ce que tout ce qu'on a appris tout
ce qu'on ne tombe
on a en réserve qu'on est vraiment riche
avec tout ça j'ai pris deux exemples des
deux de deux vaches différentes donc
notre race d'hérens
qui encore des cordes grâce à la passion
des gens qui donnent peu de lait etc
compenser ce peu de lait par la qualité
des fromages différents de chacals poche
avec les herbes les fleurs différentes
et c'est vraiment un goût différent
est-ce qu'on veut le sauvegarder pour ça
il faudra payer plus cher notre fromage
à raclette
si on veut que sa sauvegarde de plus en
plus ils doivent prendre d'autres vagues
avec ses vaches d'hérens pour pour
assurer un minimum de l'est et et je
trouve ce serait vraiment dommage est ce
qu'on a envie de la garder tout ça c'est
des choix des question qu'on peut se
poser en opposition j'ai mis la vache
industriels quel plaisir l'homme a
travaillé avec ses vaches et lavage quel
plaisir qu'elle partageait avec l'homme
et ses vaches n'ont plus de cornes ont
plu pis un sujet qui me tient à coeur
parce que l'acompte c'est très très
important pour son instinct par exemple
elle peut elle sait d'instinct que le
vif ces poisons pour elle sans cornes
elle ne sait plus et qu'elle l'ait
dégénérer on a et on a fait des lacs des
du surproductivité de l'est le paysan il
est mal payé plus de 40 à 50 centimes le
litre de lait passe y en a trop c'est
plus qu'en faire il ya plus de quotas
donc on en invente des produits lactés
des desserts lactés pour pour et les
liquides et se lève pour ça qu'on après
des ateliers rance tout tout tout à une
chaîne tout un tout un rapport après je
voulais montrer aussi parlé des bisses
les biceps aussi pôle tourisme pédestre
les murs en pierres sèches
ça fait de la grande diversité avec
c'est un petit peu vite alors avec les
murs en pierres sèches sa dune ça donne
de la vie dans les vignes il ya des les
ors des serpents iliad est dès lors très
typique des murs il ya une grande villa
et surtout ça apporte aussi un
savoir-faire aux hommes
ça donne un travail que l'on peut faire
ça donne du travail aux réfugiés aux
requérants aux chômeurs qui font un
apprentissage de mur tient et ça leur
donne une qualité de travail c'est un
savoir-faire salé grandi et en plus ça
entretient le paysage et c'est
magnifique c'est quelque chose on peut
pas faire un mur tout seul donc ça fait
du partage ça fait de l'entr'aide entre
les gens celui qui est plus faible pour
tous pour les plus petites pierres
l'autre pour les plus grosses pierres et
tandis que l'homme qui fait pour une
villa al ses murs avec ses grosses
pierres qu'est ce qui va faire les tout
seul dans sa cabine de rétro et porte
ses grosses pierres avec la machine et
le voilà quelque chose aussi qu apporte
de la vie de la diversité puis du bo
oublions pas que c'est nous qui vivons
dans ce paysage quotidien quel paysage
quotidien on a envie d'avoir ça c'était
mon paysage au début quand je faisais
pas encore en biologique c'était mon
paysage quotidien c'est-à-dire en hiver
paysage lunaire désherbants et c'est
maintenant en hiver c'est plus difficile
de faire des fleurs mais maintenant j'ai
mis j'ai mis des herbes pape l'hiver on
a dû gel donc ça on n'a pas beaucoup
d'air mais je met chaque année un
montant pour mettre des tulipes sauvages
dans les vignes et en été c'est la même
ville vous avez des fleurs des petites
fétuque valaisanne des serpolet tous des
plantes qui sont là qui apporte de la
diversité puis la vie n'est plus une
monoculture et c'est nous qui
bénéficions de ça en à voix de la
couleur en voie de la vie on voit des
insectes et papillons et il ya eu aussi
une belle chose qui est arrivé aussi en
valais il ya vingt ans en arrière on
avait plus que 20 ans étaient des
insecticides partout dans le valais pour
pour le ver de la grappe c'est un petit
papillon qui pendait eux dans la grappe
qui fait de la pourriture et à l'époque
chacun son insecticide et là on a mis
des petites capsules avec l'odeur de la
désormais du papillon fumel elle
papillons mâles ne retrouve pas sa
semelle donc elle peut pas s'accoupler
donc non pas des hauts depuis deux pays
deux pylônes revoit des papillons dans
les vignes ceux des plus gros cette fois
avec les couleurs et ces papillons avait
disparu du vignoble valaisan donc ça
c'est des choses qu'on peut faire
qu'est ce que nous on va léguer aux
futures générations qu'est ce que nous
on va pouvoir donner et ça c'était une
bonne initiative
et c'est aussi quelque chose qu'on fait
en commun avec le partage on peut pas
les chacun mettre ces petites capsules
serait trop long donc on est une sainte
130 par exemple pour le vignoble depuis
et on va poser ses capsules partout et
on est on fait des petits groupes de
cinq ou six après on fait la pose
ensemble c'est quelque chose aussi comme
pour les murs c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'on a en commun
il ya aussi la sélection de la sélection
pour les pour les pour les ceps de vigne
une époque on a sélectionné que des
cépages productif dont comprenait un
individu qu'on trouvait bien sous tous
rapports par le multiplier alors un
individu donné le 2 millions mais du
même individu
c'était une perte de la diversité
vraiment catastrophique et maintenant on
a sélectionné sur des vieilles vignes
plein d'individus par exemple de petite
arvine chaque fois on le sélectionne
impôts ces petites grappes impôts ces
grappes loge un pur pour son son
feuillage érigé tout plein de paramètres
différents qui fait qu on augmente la
diversité ils ont été sélectionnés puis
maintenant on a une sélection valais
pour la petite arvine pour les âmes
étage et c'est donc ça c'est des
initiatives qu'on fait qu'on peut faire
pour faire la biodiversité ça fait aussi
du partage
et puis de la beauté donc aussi quelque
chose que j'ai décidé de faire j'ai
acheté deux chevaux pour pouvoir faire
le travail du sol des vignes avec le
cheval alors on se dit ouais mais ça
coûte plus cher etc
mais est-ce que ça coûtera pas plus cher
dans plusieurs générations d'abord pas
penser autrement parce que c'est pas
nous qui allons le payer tout ça nos
enfants et csm un grand plaisir de
travailler avec l'animal passe l'animal
nous portent beaucoup de choses comme
lavage etc
quelque chose d'important de garder ce
rapport avec l'eau j'ai regardé combien
de temps j'ai pas compris de salé en
marche arrière donc je me disais oh j'ai
vu que c'est déjà huit minutes mais en
fait ça va
alors donc donc là pour comme résumé en
même temps je vous mets un petit film et
sur mes vignes par rapport à la première
image que vous avez vu quand j'avais
quand je faisais de la lutte
je dis pas traditionnel ça c'est pas la
tradition de faire ça la lutte de chimie
de synthèse mes vignes ressembler ce que
je vous ai montré vent puis maintenant
je vous montre mais vivent maintenant
comme elles sont en été et puis je fais
un petit résumé donc d'essayer de faire
la biodiversité et ça permet de chacun
d'être créateur on essaye de faire
autrement
donc ça nous donne des idées ça nous
permet que chacun puisse s'exprimer
et la créativité c'est le contraire de
la dépression ça nous apporte de la joie
par exemple à bord il ya des gens qu'on
crée des jardins potagers en pleine
ville est ce que je vous ai déjà donné
l'exemple ab qu'ils ont mis sept entre
le trottoir et la rue de mettre des des
bandes de prairies il faut une volonté
politique aussi un de chaque commune il
ya les jardins communautaires il ya
aussi les ai par exemple grâce à jean
marc pierre l'époque a fui avait essayé
de convaincre la commune savaient qu'ils
savaient marcher que chaque nouvelle
personne qui venait construire une ville
a fui pouvait mettre des à la place du
thuya de mettre des aides d'espèces
indigènes qui sont très colorés en
automne c'est rouge c'est magnifique
halle baguenaude j'ai aussi qui permet
aux papillons lasuré de pont-de-salars
c'est le seul c'est la seule plante hôte
de ce papillon azur et donc à la place
d'abord de monoculture le thuya le gazon
l autre villa on pourrait penser de
faire d'autres choses des échanges de
vieilles variétés de semences
aussi les vieilles variétés d'animaux
aussi des nouvelles je dis pas qu'il ya
que les vieilles variétés qui compte
mais d'essayer d'avoir la plus grande
diversité possible quand on voit par
exemple
cette agricultrice paysanne a fui
bérengère camille des chèvres toutes
sortes de variétés de chèvre avec moitié
noir moitié plein ciel sont en plus tous
les yeux pour nous ça fait du bien ça
entretient la forêt de châtaigniers sang
comme on peut dire ça sent sans bruit
des moteurs sans bruit de
débroussailleuses ça entretient c'est
beau puis elle peut faire c'est fromage
de chèvre donc tout au niveau économique
7 en plus et au niveau de la beauté
c'est un plus aussi choisir se disait
c'est des petits gestes quotidiens et
chaque fois on oublie de dire ah tiens
qu'est ce que je pourrais faire de
chaque objet utilitaire de choisir
quelque chose de beau les japonais sont
très forts ils ont très peu d'objets
mais tous les objets qu'ils ont cette
qualité aussi par exemple on dit ouais
mais quand on pique nique
c'est quand même plus pratique la
vaisselle en plastique comme ça entre la
personne qui doit faire la vaisselle
j'ai un copain qui s'appelle gilles van
acquis car c'est un concept pour manger
sans assiette sans fourchette c'est ont
fait des paniers suspendus ou on a un
petit morceau de pain de seigle qu'on
décroche comme ça compte rendant au
moose des petites brochettes tous les
choses qu'on peut manger à la main puis
chacun si chacun porte son verre ça
c'est pas le test qui doit laver tout
sévère dont le seul truc c'est porter
son verre à vin ou à sirops et puis et
puis voilà
quand on voit les bills 1 on a des beaux
objets de luxe des beaux tableaux tous
mais tous nos objets utilitaires son
match si on voit des corbeille à linge
c'est vraiment voilà j'ai pris deux
petites exemple ça sert la même chose
pour porter six bouteilles de vin quand
on quand on va justement pique nique
alors là vous avez un produit bon marché
qui vous avez la place la poussière qui
s'incruste
c'est toujours sol
ça fait toujours propre ça donne du
travail c'est une copine qui me l'effet
française
j'ai aussi pour les verts ça donne du
travail à quelqu'un c'est du beau
matériaux c'est dégradables en plus ça
tréport et puis c'est même plus facile à
porter
donc voilà je vous ai fait une petite
voilà merci